the first thing i wanted to talk about
was
uh because the winter because the summer
solstice is a great
pagan celebration and because i think we
self-consciously celebrate with the
sense
that we are participating in something
which goes slightly against the grain
of the dominator culture in which we're
embedded
and because that culture has made a
paragon
of reason i thought it might be fun
tonight
to just talk a little bit about
about reason and intuition and the forms
and the politics
that attend each so let me dig
into this a little and think aloud
reason which is
always held up as the path to true
understanding has two
forms they are called
deduction and induction
and all forms of reason can be subsumed
under these two types
now deduction which is considered
the stronger form of reason
is called reasoning from first
principles
and it works like this
you start from an idea which cannot be
proven
you accept it as given
and you reason outward from it
an example that is familiar to all of us
would be
euclid's elements of plain geometry you
start with what appears to be an
incontrovertible truth or
what we agree appears to be an
incontrovertible truth in the case of
euclid
propositions such as parallel lines
never cross never meet
well uh you can imagine a railroad in
your head and run your mind along it
to infinity and then you've inspected
the infinite railroad and lo and behold
at no point
did the rails cross so you accept this
as true
then you can reason from it
now in the case of the euclidean
proposition
that parallel lines don't meet
you test the truth of it by carrying out
this imaginary inspection
of the items involved and verifying that
the statement appears true in all cases
that you can imagine
but other forms of other branches of
human knowledge
also use
deduction interestingly enough theology
theology so theology
reasons like in the following manner
god exists this is perhaps not christian
theology this is
a generic theology god exists because
christian theology would seek to go
further back and prove in some cases
such as in scholasticism that god exists
but let's just start with the given
assumption
that god exists and then a second
assumption
and god loves us given these two
assumptions
then deduction goes to work
and elaborates an explanation for why we
are not with god
how we can get to god and so forth and
so on
so deduction is useful
notice that my two examples have been
drawn from
in the case of euclid mathematics in the
case
of the second case from theology
a branch of philosophy
so deduction seems to have an
important role in these abstract
systems but remember i said it was one
of two forms of reasoning that are
ordinarily dealt with
now the second form of reasoning
is to my mind more
interesting the second form of reasoning
is induction not deduction
induction an induction
for those who believe in it is thought
to be
without doubt a superior form
of reasoning to deduction because
it leads to a control and a manipulation
of real consequences
in the world okay what is induction
and how it works and how does it work
well it works like this
when i hit the water with a shovel
it makes a splash every time i hit the
water
with the shovel it makes a splash
therefore this is the leap therefore
therefore shovels can be used to make
water splash
now notice what is interesting about
this in in
contrast to deduction is that there is
no
untested first principle you don't
state something and then reason
from it you make repetitious
observations
and then those observations which are
most repetitious you raise to the status
of laws
induction and this
was abhorrent to philosophical thinkers
because it doesn't have this
aristotelian purity
that deduction has it doesn't have this
mathematical elegance it's messy
it's all down in the world observing and
comparing
and repeating experimentally procedures
but nevertheless out of inductive
reasoning
comes the structure of modern science
okay uh
but now there's a funny thing about
induction
it's making an unstated assumption
about time it is making
the assumption that time is invariant
because what is it is saying is if
a precedes b
in a thousand cases then it is likely
that a will precede b
in the thousand and first case in other
words it's a probabilistic theory
it assumes that probabilistic laws
give momentum to repetitious observation
now the question is is this so
and the answer is well it's so in some
cases
but not in the most interesting cases
the most interesting cases
i believe are the cases which lie in the
realm of primary experience of being
the felt experience of
being and in that realm the realm of
love affairs
divorces lawsuits religions
political upheavals and that sort of
thing
induction is no good guide at all
one love affair does not explain another
one marriage does not illuminate another
one revolution
really does not shed light on another
there may be
generalizations but when you live
through
these things what you take from them is
the uniqueness of the experience
the first principles that are reasoned
from
in uh deduction whether
in the realm of a deductive mathematical
system like euclid
or a rational theology
these things are seen to rest
on foundations of sand
because of this problem of the axiom
in mathematics the axiom appears
fairly secure because it's it's
self-evident
such as parallel lines never meet
it it's it rests on itself evidence
to make its appeal to reason
you see you can see that it is true
though no one has ever figured out how
to prove this
you can see that it is true but when you
move from the realm of axioms
to the realm of theological first
principles the appeal then is not
at all to the obviousness of
it but to the desirability of it
that god exists that god loves us
we hope these things are true
but they are certainly not self-evident
in the scheme of things from the point
of view of most of us
so what this shows then i think
is that in the matter of deeper
things deductive reasoning
rests only on the appeal that hope
can lend to its case
okay so for me this is a critique of
deduction now what about induction
i referred to the fact that its premises
rest on this notion of temporal
invariance
which seems to be true only for the
grossest of phenomena
science has made great hay in that
dimension
by creating laws
which are essentially predictive laws of
cyclical phenomena
that uh define for us what part of
reality
goes around and comes around in other
words we
we can predict simple phenomena
involving the
mechanical orbits in gravitational
fields
we can make simple predictions about the
end results of certain chemical
processes
certain nuclear processes so forth and
so on
but when you lay it against the
background of nature and experience
it begins to look like pretty thin soup
it's no basis for claiming
epistemic preeminence and this is the
point that i want to make
science claims epistemic preeminence
that means that science doesn't say
we are an ideology like buddhism and
taoism and the tarot
they say we are a meta system we
shall judge all other systems
in our scales well
this is politics but not
good philosophy because there is no
basis
for this claim to epistemic preeminence
so this somewhat egghead rave
is supposed to pass for a pagan
polemic on the
summer solstice because it's an attack
on the foundations of
reason itself and as you know when
reason goes the barbarism and madness
cannot be far behind and
as a self-declared philosophical
anarchist
as in fact the founding member of the
already
anarchist international our motto is
chaos is order
i believe that it's entirely appropriate
to carry out an attack
on uh reason
okay so then what are we left with
well what we're left with is uh
intuition intuition
and what is it and how does it work
well it's a feeling into things
that comes to answers
and leaves no trail that's the thing
it leaves no trail so you
you you have it but you haven't the
argument
for it and so its power must reside
in its uh truthfulness
so the power of intuition lies in its
ability
to express truth in contravention
to the forward flow of logic
and kazoo history well is it always to
be
this for you know how the dao
is presented as this eastern concept
that you can barely wrap your mind
around and that hovers at the edge of
intelligibility
well really in these so-called
obscure oriental uh
philosophical stances always turn out to
have
a corollary in western thinking and the
corollary to the dao
to taoism is intuitionalism
is you know an ability to sense the
the constraints and opportunities in the
moment
and act through it intuition
and intuition is always presented in the
dominator society
as one vague two feminine
three unreliable but this
is simply because of this bias
toward deductive and inductive systems
whose falsity
i have just demonstrated to you in fact
in the felt domain of experience called
living intuition is how most of us
even the most self-defined as
non-intuitional are operating
intuition is a kind of field
processing of both the foreground
and the background of experience
it's a gestalt understanding that is
subliminal
and that leads the whole organism
through an invisible set of creoles
towards the maximizing of some kind of a
goal
okay end of act one the second
act
opens in the middle of the 19th century
with science
responding albeit unconsciously
to an understanding of what i've just
said
the inadequacy of reason the necessity
of intuition
and yet all this going on in a domain of
victorian gentlemen with beards to their
belts
and a world where pianos wore pants
so you know it it worked its way out
uh subtly in the notion
of evolution and evolution
is a very interesting concept that
even those of us who profess to believe
in it i think
don't fully grasp you know what comes
in this package we all
are taught that
in the 19th century a great struggle was
waged between science and religion
because
science had the audacity to suggest
that human beings were descended from
the great apes
and we all know who took what sides
and the kind of polemics that were
raised
and we all know the happy ending of this
story with the great triumph of modern
evolutionary
biology however
that to my mind looking at it from the
point of view of a philosopher
is all sham
or it's like the 11 o'clock news version
of what actually happened that's how
rather silly people understood
the great intellectual watershed
struggle
of the 19th century that is not in fact
what it was about
that's not what it was about the
outrageous assertion of the
evolutionists of
darwin particularly and his school was
not
that human beings were descended from
the great apes
in fact the outrageous assertion wasn't
even
contained in the part of the manuscript
that was called
the descent of man you recall it was
called
the origin of species and the descent of
man
and where the real kicker was lodged
was in the origin of species why
because darwin set out to show
that nature could be the product
of processes without purpose
that was the bit that brought the roof
down ordinary people couldn't understand
this this is called the so-called
teleological issue
but this is what brought the christian
church
roaring to its feet in confrontation
with evolutionary biology the assertion
that nature could be accounted for
by processes that were not guided
toward a higher end by a higher power
that's simply random molecular processes
and then pressures of environmental
selection
could cause to come to be animals plants
and ultimately human beings
but the fight was over teleology
the fight was over whether or not the
universe
has a purpose toward which
all creation moves inelectably
or whether nature is what the darwinists
called it which was
trendlessly fluctuating
trendlessly fluctuating so it was an
attack on god
not the divinity not the divine status
of man
that was peanuts in this poker game
it was an attack on the need for god
per se as an efficient
cause in the machinery of universal
being
well it's a very interesting question
and a very interesting struggle
because we are still caught up in it
american transcendentalism while all
this was going on in england
american transcendentalism was exploring
the transcendental realms of the human
spirit
cast against the background of the
american landscape
and this
question of the telos in nature
was you know to make friends
lifelong friends into enemies and sunder
families alfred russell wallace
who was the co-discoverer of evolution
with darwin
really preceded him he he
uh had a fever he was a
professional butterfly collector as i
was once in my youth
and on the island of ternate in eastern
indonesia
wallace fell into a malarial fever
and at the height of this fever he wrote
down a page and a half of scribbling
which when he came down from this
illness and read it
it seemed to hold up and what he had
discovered was what all
biology was seeking what he called the
solution to the problem of the species
and he looked at this thing and what it
was was a description of natural
selection
and it seemed to work well wallace was
from the lower classes and made his
living in england as a surveyor was
essentially a field biologist because he
was not
accepted by the gentleman scientists of
england
he didn't know where to turn
so he fired off a letter to the only
person he could think of to
ask who was the greatest biologist of
the day
charles darwin at home in england in his
garden working over
20 years of notes on the problem of the
species
when darwin got this letter from this
unknown
character postmarked ambon dutchy
stindis
and read it he paled visibly
and he went to his friend sir charles
lyle
who was the great the greatest geologist
of the day the proponent of
catastrophism and one of the great
was to develop into one of the great
defenders of darwin's theory
he went to charles lyle and said
i've been working 20 years on this idea
this came in the post
this this is it it's all here
and lyle said don't worry my friend we
will schedule
two papers to be delivered at the royal
society they will be delivered on the
same evening
and yours shall be first and so it was
and so it comes down to us as darwin's
theory of evolution but in fact
in a way for philosophical purists
it may have been better that way
because wallace
who was in many ways a deeper thinker
than darwin was a fabian
socialist was fascinated by paranormal
phenomena
as well as being interested in
electricity
biogeography anthropology
truly one of the last of the great
polymaths
wallace was unable to take the final
step
on the question of teleology and he said
i cannot believe that random
processes ameliorated by natural
selection
can give rise to a creature
such as man so this was
the break in the 19th century and it uh
it arises out of the earlier foundation
of the struggle between intuition and
reason
i mean i think our intuition must
place us in wallace's camp
that there is a telos
of some sort there is an omega point
toward which all creation however
unsteadily
moves and it is because of this
uh omega point that we do live in a
cosmos
and not a child not simply a raging
confusion
but something that is structured and
ordered
well in spite of the fact that evolution
was seeking to
serve the most rigorous scientific
desires
to exclude teleology and to
exclude god from the process
of the natural world
it introduced a bizarre concept
which cut against its own purposes the
concept is
a kind of progress
in nature where previously
none had been so that
from aristotle to the 19th century
what you have as a theory of nature
is what's called the great chain of
being or the great
ladder of being and it stretches from
god
through the archangels the cerebellum
the cherubim down man
then the animal kingdom the vegetable
kingdom
so forth and so on but it is imagined
as static as
put in place by the fiat
looks of creation set in place
for all time what what
darwin did was to see it
as not a great chain of being but as an
escalator of being he added the notion
of progressive movement toward higher
and higher
forms more and more complex
manifestations
of the intrinsic
ingression of novelty into actual events
and this idea
is very very interesting and cogent
and pregnant with possibility for all of
us and our world
you see what it is really is it's a
recasting of an
idea that had been banished for several
centuries from western thinking
it is the alchemical idea
that nature is driving to perfect itself
this was what the alchemists believed
they believed that
through time uh lesser metals
became gold and that what the alchemist
was trying to do
was to compress time
he was trying to to catalyze
a natural process so that what took
thousands in their imagination
of years in the body of the earth
could be compressed into days or weeks
in the alembic
of the alchemist well as science defined
itself in the throughout the 17th and
18th century under the impetus of
descartes
and and kant and all of these people
this notion of the world as a distillate
apparatus was given up but it returns
in the idea of evolution and uh
we inherit it in the social world
now this is a delicate point there is
something called
social darwinism otherwise known
as fascism social darwinism
uses a very vulgar understanding of
evolutionary dynamics
to justify class oppression
by saying that
it must be right that some people have
their
foot on other people's necks because
isn't this what nature is about
struggle of the fittest and survival of
the
the longest fang the swiftest
claw the sharpest tooth well
the answer is no absolutely not this
this rests on an understanding of nature
that was in vogue 150 years ago
that is not in vogue now that's what you
see
when you look at nature at the at the
in the human dimension but when you
analyze nature
as a an integrated system of chemical
reactions
gene transfer catalytic self-regulating
activities
hyper cycles of energy nutrients and
metabolism
when you analyze nature from that point
of view you see
that it seeks to maximize cooperation
connectedness mutual interdependability
is the thing which holds the whole thing
together
and the species that is most successful
is not the species that can dominate all
others
it's the species that can make itself
indispensable
to all others look at the uh
evolutionary success of the bacteria
you know they settled in for the long
haul and
no higher form of life can
operate without them and so the
the possibility of bacteria becoming
extinct is
laughable i mean they'll be the last to
go because they have made themselves
indispensable this idea then of
evolution
has strongly entered the human world
and science hates this
i had somebody once say to me if it
doesn't involve
genes it ain't evolution
and you should not use the word
evolution to describe
progressive change they didn't like that
they said evolution is a technical term
used by biologists and it applies to
genetic material only
books do not evolve social systems do
not evolve corporations relationships
do not evolve this is a misuse of the
word
well since then uh evolutionary thinkers
like c.h waddington eric yanch west
churchman
paul feirob and irvin laszlo
have i think by the sheer force
and volume of their writings overwhelmed
this notion
and reclaimed evolution as
a much broader concept
than it was understood to be in the 19th
century
evolution is now understood to be the
triumphant
march out of chaos into order
connectedness
self-expression and self-reflection that
begins with the first
moments following the big bang
in other words we have uh
chemical we have atomic evolution
evolution of atomic systems as electrons
settle down into stable orbits
we have chemical evolution into more and
more complex molecular forms which
finally become
polymers these polymers further evolve
into complex energetic systems
capable of self-replication motility
and eventually you know the writing of
operas
so what we see when we look at
uh the universe is that
you have to be blind to this progressive
tendency
that has worked its will with the random
plasma of pure electrons with the
chemistry of stars
with the molecular chemistry of
primitive planets
with plant and animal life
with human epigenetic coding systems
carving dance ritual vocalization
magic and this process proceeds
right up into the 20th century with this
phenomenon
that we all give some
credence to the notion that we are
living in a period
of compressed time
[Music]
you